in this video let's delve deeper and get
even better intuition about what the
cost function is doing this video
assumes that you're familiar with
contour plots if you're not familiar
with contour plots or contour figures
some of the illustrations in this video
may or may not make sense to you but
it's okay and if you end up skipping
this video or if some of it doesn't
quite make sense because you haven't
seen contour plots before that's okay
and you still understand the rest of
this course without those parts of it
here's our problem formulation as usual
with the hypothesis parameters cost
function and our optimization objective
unlike before unlike the last video I'm
going to keep both of my parameters
theta 0 and theta 1 as we generate our
visualizations for the cost function so
same as last time we want to understand
the hypothesis H and the cost function J
so here's my training set of housing
prices and let's make some hypothesis
you know like that one this is not a
particularly good hypothesis but if I
set theta 0 equals 50 and theta one
equals 0.06 then I end up with this
hypothesis down here and that
corresponds to that straight line now
given these values of theta zero and
theta one we want to plot the
corresponding you know cost function on
the right what we did last time was
regular where we only had theta one you
know we're drawing plots that look like
this as a function of theta one but now
we have two parameters theta zero and
theta one and so the plot gets a little
more complicated it turns out that when
we have only one parameter the plus we
drew had this sort of bow shaped
function now when we have two parameters
it turns out the cost function also has
a similar sort of bow shape and in fact
depending on your training set you might
get a cost function that maybe looks
something like this so this is a 3d
surface plot where the axes are labeled
theta 0 and theta
one so as you vary theta zero and theta
one to two parameters you get different
values of the cost function J of theta
zero comma theta one and the height of
the surface above a particular point of
theta zero theta one right that's the
vertical axis the height of the surface
at the point indicates the value of J of
theta zero comma J of theta one and you
can see it sort of has this bow like
shape let me show you the same part in
3d so here's the same figure in 3d with
axis a zero theta one and vertical axis
J of theta zero theta one and if I
rotate this your plot around you kind of
get a sense I hope this bell shaped
surface is that's what the cost function
J looks like now for the purpose of
illustration in the rest of this video
I'm not actually going to use these
sorts of 3d surfaces to show you the
cost function J instead I'm going to use
contour plots or what I also call
contour figures
I guess they mean the same thing to show
you these surfaces so here's an example
of a contour figure shown on the right
where the axes are theta zero and theta
one and one of each of these ovals what
each of these ellipses shows is a set of
points that takes on the same value for
J of theta zero theta one so completely
for example let's you know take that
point at that point at that point all
three of these points like just drew a
magenta they have the same value for J
of theta zero theta one okay where write
these this is a theta zero theta one
axis but those three have the same value
for J of theta zero comma theta one and
if you haven't seen console parts much
before think of imagine if you will a
bowl shape function that's coming out at
my screen so that the minimum so the
bottom of the bowl is this
right there right this middle the middle
of these concentric ellipses and imagine
a bow shape that's of grows out my
screen like this so that each of these
ellipses you know has the same height
above my screen and the minimum of the
bow right is right down there and so the
contour figures is a way to is it maybe
a more convenient way to visualize my
function J so let's look at some
examples over here I have a particular
point right and so this is a with you
know theta zero equals me about eight
hundred and feita one equals maybe a
minus 0.15 and so this point right is
this point in red corresponds to one
Pacific pair of values of theta zero
comma theta one and they correspond in
fact to that hypothesis right with theta
zero is about 800 meters intersects the
vertical axis around 800 and this is a
slope of about minus 0.15 now this line
is really not such a good fit to the
data right this hypothesis H of X with
these values of theta 0 theta 1 3 not
such a good fit to the data and so you
find that is cost as a value that's out
here let's feel pretty far from the
minimum right so it's pretty far it's in
a pretty high cost because this is just
not that good fit to the data let's look
at some more examples now here's the
different hypothesis that's you know
still not a great fit of the data there
may be slightly better so here right
that's my point
that those are my parameters theta zero
theta one and so my theta zero value
right that's um about 360 and my value
for theta one is equal to 0 so you know
let's write that out the state of 0
equals 360 theta 1 equals 0 and this
pair of parameters corresponds to that
hypothesis corresponds to a flat line
right this is H of x equals
360 plus zero times X so that's my
hypothesis and this hypothesis again has
some cost and that causes you know
plotted as the height of the J function
at that point let's look at just a
couple of examples here's one more you
know at this value of theta zero and
then that value of theta one we end up
with this hypothesis H of X and again
not a great fit to the data and just I
can move even further out for the
mineral last example this is actually
not quite at the minimum but it's pretty
close to minimum so this is not such a
bad fit to the to the data where for a
particular value of theta zero which
whatever this value is in for a
particular value of theta one we get a
particular H of X and this is this is
not quite at the minimum is pretty close
and so the sum of squares errors or some
squares distances between my training
examples and my hypothesis every that's
the sum of squared distances right of
all of these errors this is pretty close
to the minimum even though it's not
quite a minimum so with these figures I
hope that gives you a better
understanding of what values of the cost
function J and how they are and how that
corresponds to different hypotheses as
well as how better hypotheses may
correspond to points that closer to the
minimum of this cost function J now of
course what we really want is an
efficient algorithm like your efficient
piece of software for automatically
finding the value of theta zero and
theta one that minimizes the cost
function J what we don't want to do is
to you know have to write software to
plot out this point and then try to
manually read off we don't do that this
is not a good way to do it and in fact
we'll see later that when we look at
more complicated examples will have
higher dimensional figures with more
parameters that that it turns out we'll
see if you will see in maintenance cause
examples where this figure you cannot
really be plotted is becomes much harder
to visualize and so what we want is to
have software to find the value of theta
0 thing
then minimizes this function and in the
next video we'll start to talk about an
algorithm for automatically finding that
value of theta zero and theta one that
minimizes the cost function J